-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers
and this is "Late Night."
And we hope you all
had a great --
as Shoemaker likes
to call it --
Hump Day.
[ Laughter ]
Let's get to the news!
President Biden
yesterday criticized
Republican-led efforts to pass
new, restrictive voting laws
and said, "Have you no shame?"
Said Republicans, "What if w
made voting cost 40 bucks?
Pop star Olivia Rodrigo me
with President Biden
and Dr. Anthony Fauci toda
to discuss
coronavirus vaccine outreach
That story, again -- America's
number one teen idol met
with Joe Biden
and Olivia Rodrigo.
[ Laughter ]
Republican Senator Ted Cru
announced yesterday
that he raised more
than $5 million last quarter
And, based on his look,
I'm going to guess he did it
with a dunk tank?
[ Laughter ]
According to a new book
about the 2020
presidential race,
Rudy Giuliani suggested,
on election night,
that President Trump
just claim victory
before state races
had been called, saying,
"Just say we won."
Which I think is
how he became a lawyer.
[ As Giuliani ]
I'm a lawyer.
[ Laughter ]
According to the same book
Eric Trump flipped out
on his father's
campaign data "uh-nah" --
analyst -- excuse me --
as results began coming in
on election night, and yelled,
"Where are these votes
coming from?"
To be fair,
he reacts the same way
to the fridge ice maker.
[ As Eric ]
Whoa!
[ Laughter ]
Where is this ice coming from?
Is this some sort of magic
Five members of one family
in Texas were reportedly charged
with participating in the
January attack on the Capitol.
And, if you think that's bad
wait 'til you hear
what five members
of this family did.
[ Laughter ]
Apple, yesterday, unveiled
a new, magnetic battery pack
which attaches to the back
of the phone to charge.
They say it's the most
convenient system
you'll ever leave
in a hotel room.
[ Laughter ]
McDonald's franchisees
are reportedly planning
to offer employees
emergency childcare,
in an effort
to bring in new workers.
It's called the ball pit.
"Alright,
I'll see you in a few hours.
Hey, if there's fries
down there, don't you eat 'em.
[ Laughter ]
When asked,
in an interview yesterday,
about a lawsuit alleging
the use of fake tuna
in their sandwiches,
the CEO of Subway said
the chain uses real fish
and added,
"We 100% stand behind our tuna
But only because that's
usually downwind."
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
hundreds of used syringes
washed up on New Jersey beache
after last week's
excessive rainfall.
It's a bad sign
for climate change.
Usually, the New Jersey syringes
don't show up until September.
[ Laughter ]
And that was a monologue,
everybody.